today's topic there's another video uh
from rapper named soweto she went on hot
97 a couple years ago and decided to do
some raps for some of the hip hop hosts
so i'm gonna play the video she seems
like she's here for it i think we should
definitely do it yeah
why why yeah way of the face
because i can be very critical oh you
know
and you seem like a nice person and she
also looks like she's not scared of you
so she's ready
and you're calling me because i do
disclaimers
i'd clown him if he was in person too
perfect just keep the same energy i
always keep the same amount of amen
i shouldn't be trying to go easy all
right right
tell him and tell him i mean we just
gonna do whatever we do and if you like
it you like it if you don't then
that's it that's the attitude let's see
how you should have i'm mad at it
sweetie see what these raps
they be dancing i could better see the
clock tick tock whoa that me a girl real
icy that means i don't got times for
girls that don't like me
i be minding my own [ __ ] but they check
up on me like a parent as they keep
how does that really feel you don't know
me and don't like me that's a very
special skill [ __ ]
uh well let me share a little something
my skin is real light but i like my
liquid dark let me get something one
henny if i'm chilling out the bar how
the fish is in the water but i'm feeling
like a shark like my weather from the
west and my [ __ ] from the east
i'm looking like a beauty but i'm moving
like a bee sweets easter beat
got me on repeat if you didn't know i'm
the eighth wonder to see
if you asking about who's hot you better
ask about me i don't know what's finding
women with a college degree
how to gossip when you're too busy out
being a queen gossip and don't get money
so that ain't in my routine
[ __ ]
it had energy
what a way to end it it had energy you
know what that's like
it's like you just get done clapping a
girl you're like how was that baby she's
like
well you were very enthusiastic
imagine if the way that people define
your bedroom game was enthusiasm hey man
listen
as the king of writing trash bars i just
want to welcome you to my kingdom okay
we are accepting all applicants and you
have
not only been accepted habibi you've
been fast-tracked okay
you are now a deputy of trash bar
kingdom okay
i trash bars the way i trash but that's
what she came to be judged
on she said uh you know rapidly rap i do
that right i write really well right
good bars
okay cool your bars are trash yeah
that's it they are you know all this
stuff i'm not talking about her as an
artist nobody's saying that
but they're very basic yeah yeah her
bars are not good very big you know she
raps like an open mic or goes
on yeah on the stage not a good open mic
an open mic or open micro that starts
starts
that's it and so if you blowing up with
these bars you know maybe
your music's good maybe you know you're
you're you're in a song
you sound way better maybe with all that
but like as far as your wrapping skills
you're trash and it's okay and it's okay
doesn't mean that you're involved as an
artist but yo listen
it is what it is you need more work i
mean kanye when he first came out he
needed a whole lot of work he was
dusty yeah but how does she take it he's
still fresh kanye
kanye kanye is not a good rapper
as far as like bars go he's not i'm not
saying he doesn't have some good bars
but
you look at his body of work no one
putting kanye at the top as a rapper
like lyricist or anything like that
i see what you're saying yeah yeah yeah
but as an artist
yeah yeah i've never heard someone but
kanye my top 10 is a rapper for rap
albums are good but it's like the
production the beat meeting it's not
just the boss bars you don't go
to kanye for barber but
you know what i'm gonna leave it that
cool because i know the young girl's
working
and i got to be honest if you was a dude
i would probably be hard on you
i'll be honest yes i said what your
issue is what did you like
i just thought the raps was basic i just
thought the raps was basic
and i think you need to honestly i think
you need to honestly get a little sharp
on your addiction
your clarity and your content if you're
gonna impress me
and that's what he said and that was a
very fair criticism right and it's also
important to note like
she asked for yeah he wasn't overly
rough he didn't say anything beyond just
like hey man that [ __ ] was pretty basic
he didn't even want to put her on like
that yeah it's not the proper setting no
i want this i want a rap rap i want to
show
she won that and then when he came how
did she take it she said she got ptsd
from the
she said she got ptsd from that dead ass
that was her work
like that was a dark time i left when i
heard him say all that stuff that's
insulting
that's very insulting and here's the
thing guys you know not being good at
something in your craft is good it's
humbling it means you have room to
improve
and you know your ceiling is way high
that's what it means so
you coming in thinking you were all that
with your raps like you weren't
you aren't as far as i know and it's
good to be told that
because it helps you improve i think
it's way more toxic to have people who
gass you up when you trash
than to have people tell you the truth
when you ask for it me personally
i don't know how you guys want it but am
i going to feel bad for her am i going
to no i think you're being a big baby
personally
when you ask for feedback and someone
gives it to you in an honest way
and he gave you a lot of outs he said
you don't have to ask don't ask me and
you insisted so
it's just like what are you in this game
for if not to get better you want
somebody to stroke your ego then go
somewhere else
you know that annoys me when people come
to me and they're like
what do you think i'm like you don't
want to ask me no no please i want you
to listen to my music i'm like bro you
don't want
she was trash i didn't like the
production i didn't like your bars the
hook was terrible i don't know who that
random girl is that you brought on
you know like i'll tell you but don't
ask me if you don't want the truth and
don't claim victimhood afterwards
when you got what you asked for but
anyways
i digress that's all i thought ptsd
that's insulting
ptsd is a real condition there's real
things to ptsd there's a real
settings to ptsd what are you telling me
that from this interview you're dreaming
about that at night
you're having flashback of that you
relive that moment
is that what's going on ptsd is a real
thing it's a real condition you have to
check some boxes to fit in that that's
not ptsd
you don't have ptsd what you have is
shame you got a shame because you taught
you
was hot because the thing around the
people around you are acting like your
mother
oh yes child you look you're doing good
you're doing good out there
when you're doing trash that is not ptsd
what you're feeling
it's shame shame that's what you that's
not ptsd the rhymes were basic you
asked for it i can't go to a gym a
sparring gym
and i put my gloves on and i start
sparring with people and i get roughed
up and say
i have ptsd for that when i'm the one to
ask for it
yo mike tyson you want to spar with me
and then say i got ptsd for that
you asked and it was not even tyson
listen the only people who got ptsd are
the ones who witnessed that trash ass
rap okay
i just learned to write songs maybe like
um
at the beginning of this year because i
was a freestyle rapper i love just
writing a beat writing song is hard
some of the best people out there that
do songs
most of them don't write them performing
a song is one thing
writing your song is another thing
writing and performing is another thing
so if you're good you're good i mean
what's wrong why why are you cringing
i'm not i'm just trying to figure it out
what when people
rap to any kind of song thing but
rapping especially if you're lying make
me believe it
there's a thing about the person we know
rick ross is a fraud
he didn't move any keys but there's
something that he can make
us believe that there's something about
the swag and the way
there's a persona there's a persona
rapping is a bit
like wrestling you know what your
persona is that's what i do
and and i i don't know man i don't know
how to put my finger on it there's
something missing there
my brother she wraps it's not just the
bars i've heard some but
i've heard some trash bars but there was
some hype to it
there was something to it i've heard
trash bars and i was like yeah but this
is it was
but that's what she came to be judged on
your bars was trash
you asked for the advice you got told
that's it after that stop complaining
stop complaining and this is the truth
man something i'll be coddling a lot of
these artists
some of them are trash at certain parts
it's not because you're a good lyricist
that you're necessarily good in the
production state
i know plenty of dudes who can rap they
try to produce their own music and it's
garbage
it happens you can't be good at
everything so you know get humbled good
for you
it's my thoughts anything sit down
sit down and i know some of you guys
might be confused at this moment you
can't understand why it's because we're
on opposite sides
you're welcome
we finally haven't reached hey
[Music]
foreign